what i want to do in this video is think
about the idea of a fraction
and for the sake of of this video as we
just learned what a fraction is you can
really think of it as a part of a whole
later on we'll think of it in even in
even more ways what do i mean by a part
of a whole
so let's imagine that we have a pizza
i'll do it in a pizza colored so i'll do
an orange i guess that's roughly the
color of a pizza pizza i guess is yellow
and kind of red for the tomato sauce the
yellow for the cheese so let's say this
was a perfect circle i'm going to try my
best to draw a circle right over here
and let's say that i divide it into four
equal parts
so
just like that i've divided it into two
equal parts
and now i will divide it into four equal
parts
so there's total of four slices four
equal slices of this pizza
four equal slices of this pizza and
let's say on three of the slices i have
cheese only cheese
only
only cheese and let's say on this
on this fourth slice i have cheese and i
don't know i have olives
i have olives right over here so we can
ask ourselves what fraction of this
pizza has olives on it
well we have four total slices they all
have they're all equal slices we have
four equal sections here
and one of those equal sections has
olives so we could say one fourth of
this pizza one fourth of
the pizza
the pizza
has
has olives
has olives one out of the four
now someone said well what fraction of
this pizza only has cheese
well this fraction has cheese but it
also has olives so we won't count that
but then we have one two three three
fractions three of these equal pieces
have only cheese so we could say three
out of a total of four pieces
of so three fourths of the pizza
of the pizza
has
only
only
only cheese let's do a couple more
examples because this is probably one of
the most important and most useful ideas
that you can have in your brain so let's
do another another few examples so this
is what we sliced up a pizza
let's imagine
instead that we're looking at a
some some animals of some go say fruit
fruit is easier for me to draw
so let's say that i have
i have an orange
i have an orange so that's an orange
right over there
and i have a
banana
i have a banana so that's my best
attempt at drawing a banana
right over here
and i have a lemon
i have a
lemon
just like that and let's say that i have
i have an apple
i'll draw
i will draw let's see actually i'll draw
an apple
it's a little bit of a strange color for
an apple but we'll go with it so
that is my apple right over there and
actually let me draw one more let me
draw let me draw a grape
a grape or grapes so i have a bunch of
grapes
right over here
and if i were to ask you at least the
way that it is drawn
what fraction of my fruit that i have
is
let's say
is yellow
is yellow what fraction of my fruit as
drawn is yellow
well we could say we have we have a
total of one two three four five pieces
of fruit
so there's a total of five pieces of
fruit and then what fraction of that of
those pieces of fruit are yellow well i
have two the way i drew it i have two
yellow pieces right over here so we'd
say two-fifth
of
the
fruit
of the fruit is and it's strange that
i'm writing this in white so i'll write
it in yellow is
is yellow two-fifths is yellow
let me do one more example to just
really make the point clear
so let me draw a candy bar this is all
food related i guess it's getting close
to dinner time i apologize so let's say
i have a candy bar just like that
and let me divide it into
let me divide it into five equal pieces
one
two
three
four that doesn't look too equal so the
whole point is to do it equals one
two
three
four that looks pretty close so let's
assume that these are equal pieces so my
drawing isn't perfect but let's assume
all of these pieces are equal
and i'm hungry
so let's say that i eat
i eat this piece
and i eat this piece so they essentially
go away
so what fraction of the pieces have i
eaten
well i have a total of five pieces
there's a total of five equal sections
of this candy bar i guess i could say
and i ate two of them so two-fifths
two-fifths of this bar so this is you
know i've literally i've i've taken them
away two-fifths of
the
bar
have been eaten
have been eaten
so i'll leave you there maybe i'll make
another video that doesn't have as many
food analogies but this is a super
useful concept and i encourage you to
think about this as much as possible and
then try the exercises on khan academy